so the whole popping of cassette tape
into the boom box and banging your head
off the wall
that was all part of an invocation i
guess right so my big burning question
after the finale is
what's the memory that uncle george has
tucked away in his brain
that involves him having a great time
listening to love shaq
hey guys pete here today i'm gonna do my
best to explain the
ending of servant season two it's the
kind of show you expect to twist in
and we did get that although it was a
little bit different than what i was
expecting
and all in all it turned out to be
pretty satisfying a quick spoiler
warning
if you haven't completed season two in
its entirety yet then this video won't
be for you
it'll definitely spoil it so go watch it
and then come back and hit the subscribe
button while you're here so you won't
lose your way
with that said let's get started
sermon's a great looking show with a
great cast
a really interesting premise that the
whole thing basically takes place in
this town house
and it's a show that relies heavily on
mystery season one played with the idea
that there were all these inexplicable
things that kept happening
which could all possibly be explained
with rational explanations
or there could be something supernatural
going on
it made for some fun in guessing what
was happening but also made you worry
that it might go down the road of
endless red herrings continuing to pile
mysteries on top of more mysteries
in season 2 we started to get a steady
stream of answers
primarily that yes leanne does have
powers
it also took the turner family in a
direction that makes it difficult to
have any sympathy for them heading into
the finale
sure dorothy has real issues that stem
from a horrible thing that happened to
her real-life
son jericho but now she's taken a
teenage girl prisoner
she's waking up in the middle of the
night and torturing her
she buried her alive and the people
closest to
her her brother julian and her husband
sean refused to tell her the truth
and bring things to an end the second
season shifts from a family dealing with
a tragedy
to a group of bad people making bad
decisions
in order to try to get a child that they
know isn't theirs to begin with back
in order to keep a lie going it also
fills in the details of leanne's awful
childhood
she had a self-centered abusive mother
who would never give her what she craved
most her acceptance and love even with
the king cake her mother always found
the baby
so that she could say she was special
and use that as a reason to put leanne
down
even though now we see that leanne is in
fact special
she's still in search of a mother's love
and in the end that does turn out to be
the big twist
despite everything that happened despite
her concerns that dorothy was incapable
of taking care of the baby
her act of saving leanne fulfilled that
desire
and now leanne wants to stay with the
turners and create a family
so to recap what happened in the finale
it does pick up right where
episode 9 left off aunt josephine at the
front door
with the betamax machine in tow and
leanne watching from jericho's room
holding the doll
shawn and dorothy let her in she tries
to comfort dorothy
who really only wants the baby back and
when they ask about aunt may and uncle
george she says they're not involved in
this anymore
dorothy agrees to let her talk to leanne
and when she hears that leanne wants to
stay there
she assures her that they don't love her
and we get the idea that as confused as
leanne
is the idea of going back to the church
of the lesser
saints doesn't sound like a great idea
at the same time it's clear that they
still have
some power over her aunt josephine goes
to tell dorothy that her and leanne are
leaving tonight but tells her that she
made a promise that she wants to keep so
she hands her the onesie
that we saw back in season one and when
asked she says it's the truth
and it almost looks like dorothy's gonna
wake up here she's gonna remember what
happened
she locks herself in the room we see
that sean's phone stops working
and then he gets locked in the other
room and it starts to look like leanne
isn't the only person in the house who
has powers
probably my favorite thing in the finale
on the first watch
was the betamax it definitely gave off
some lost
dharma initiative vibes and aunt
josephine's showing her this
as a warning about what will happen if
she doesn't ask for forgiveness
so now we understand what uncle george
was doing in love shack there's an
invocation a consecration
and then an emancipation and essentially
this is something that they need to do
when one of their members leaves the
cult or loses their way
the fact that he talks about taking out
their eyes makes it sound like this is
what roscoe saw
when he was with them we heard him
talking about taking out the
eyes and throwing them away when he was
hypnotized and i don't know about you
but if it was me
i would definitely do whatever aunt
josephine said in order to avoid this
ritual and at first that is what leanne
does
but things fall apart when leanne won't
say that she'll forget dorothy turner
and josephine says it's a sin to covet
someone even a mother
and then she splashes her in the eyes
with the liquid from the wooden box
and goes downstairs to start the
invocation
listening to pennies from heaven and
stabbing herself
repeatedly in the thigh with a fork
really fun stuff
dorothy is not having fun she's actually
decided that she's going to kill herself
and it leads to a pretty emotional
conversation between her and sean
as a couple people who have been
consistently making bad decisions
and doing bad things it was a little
surprising how much this scene actually
worked
downstairs leanne has made it to the
basement and josephine
is pursuing she tries to escape it
doesn't work
and now that the invocation has been
completed and josephine continues with
the ritual
which involves a gruesome slashing of
the limbs
to everyone's surprise dorothy shows up
hits her with a shovel
and saves the anne and for this leanne
says
look she wanted you to think he's gone
he's not gone i'm gonna bring him back
to you
it's what dorothy has been waiting to
hear when she leaves we hear leanne say
she protected me
like i'm her daughter and again this
really landed like a gut punch
think about how bad your relationship
with your family had to be
how bad of an experience being with the
cult would have to have been
in order for you to still really want
dorothy to be your mother
and josephine's down but she's not out
she does come back as leanne is
heating the knife over the pyre that she
lit the one that uncle george left there
a couple episodes back but in the end
leanne gets the upper hand
she stabs her right through the eye and
we don't see it it happens off screen
but it looks like she throws her on the
fire
and then one way or another gets her
upstairs where we see
her charred body in the crawl space
between the walls
after everything that happened sean is
finally ready to tell dorothy the truth
he's right there it's the next thing
he's about to say
and of course dorothy doesn't want to
hear anything she's just waiting for the
baby to come back
and she turns on the baby monitor and
she hears
leanne singing so they go into the
baby's room and lo and behold there she
is
she's wearing a coat and she's holding
the baby in her arms
and she gives him to dorothy there's
really no explanation of how she did
this
the fact that she's wearing the coat
makes it look like she went outside
after stashing aunt josephine's body
however she did that but at this point
it really doesn't matter because
yeah she has power so something related
to her powers made this all possible
the big takeaway is that she says now we
can be a family
so dorothy gets what she wants she gets
the baby back
and what she wants is what shawn wants
basically and leanne's been saved by
dorothy
which translates to her as a mother's
love
the little girl inside her the pageant
contestant the one who saw dorothy
and imagine this wonderful mother who
was so much better than her own
has decided to leave the cult behind and
make this her family
it's not a happy ending though we hear
her say
i don't know why i keep doing bad things
i can feel the dark thing inside me
getting bigger we see the lights flicker
in the room and the house and then we
see that go down the block
she says i'm tired of everyone telling
me what's wrong with me maybe there's
nothing wrong maybe this is who i
am and then she says i know how this
works
i know they're coming from me don't
worry i'll be ready
i know killing you referring to aunt
josephine
started a war and so season two ends
with the answer that yes leanne has
powers and the question becoming then
where do these powers come from we've
seen both uncle george
and aunt josephine appear to have some
powers of their own
does that mean everyone in the cult has
that and probably more importantly
where does that power come from we hear
them refer to a hymn
and the easy answer there is that
they're referring to a god
but perhaps there is an actual person
someone above aunt josephine that we're
gonna meet next season
a pretty healthy balance of answered
questions and ongoing mystery
i definitely like the idea that the big
question
shifts to being more about leanne about
who she is how she has these powers what
she's capable of
than just being about jericho i thought
they did a pretty good job of circling
back
and pulling on some of those threads
that have been dangling there since the
beginning
i think there's a pretty good chance
that julian got leanne
pregnant we didn't see any julian in the
finale and then getting together seems
like it's gonna have implications
i would say uncle george probably
survived getting hit by the car
i doubt we've seen the last of him when
we first saw aunt josephine's face in
the basement
i initially thought when i saw the
scarring what looked like a burn on her
face that perhaps she was leanne's birth
mother
with more thought though that doesn't
seem very likely there's quite a few
other options
considering her connection with the cult
it could be that she was there when that
fire that dorothy covered happened or it
could be the fact that they do
all this kind of violent stuff so i
don't think it was hinting that she was
leanne's mother
what does war look like between the cult
and the turner family
where are things gonna go next i think
it's the kind of finale that gives me
hope that the rest of the series will be
interesting
we know that they've already started
filming season three
and that they're planning on doing four
seasons total
and i'm excited to see where it goes and
i think i'll leave it there so let me
know in the comments what you thought
about the finale
what you thought about season two in
general in all your theories about where
you think
things go from here please like this
video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon
you